>>> OVER 100 MEMBERS OTHE
NAONAL GUARD ACTIVATED.
LAWYERS CALLING FOR A FEDERAL
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION IN
MASSACHUSETTS.
AND UNLIKELY FRONT IN AN UGLY
MIGRANT STAND OFFER.
TRKS SENTS MIGRANTS TO NEW YORK
CITY.
HERE'S WHAT MAYOR ADAMS TOLD
CNN.
>> THIS IS AS STATED A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS CREATED BY
HUMAN HANDS AND AN ALL HANDS ON
DECK MOMENT TO COME TOGETHER AND
COORDINATE.
COORDINATION IN A CRISIS IS
SOMETHING TO DO TOGETHER.
>> LET'S BRING IN CNN POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR VAN JONES AND
BARBARA COMSTOCK.
WE HEARD THE MAYOR TALKING ABOUT
HOW AT THE VERY LEAST THEY DON'T
GET THE COORDINATION WITH THE
GOVERNORS BEFORE THE MIGRANTS
ARE DROPPED OFF WHY WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF WHAT THEY ARE UP TO?
>> IT IS SHAMEFUL.
THERE IS A WAY TO HANDLE THIS.
WE NEED MORE IMMIGRATION AND NOT
LESS.
IT WOULD HELP WITH INFLATION AND
EVERYTHING ELSE.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS A
COMPLETE BREAK DOWN AND YOU NEED
FOR SOMEONE LIKE DESANTIS TO
CONVENE THE GOVERNORS.
USE A BIPARTISAN GROUP TO DO
MORE AND COORDINATE IT.
THEY ARE JUST DOING THE STUNTS
AND THE AMBUSHES TO SCORE
POLITICAL POINTS AND SO IT'S
ACTUALLY -- THEY ARE I WOULD SAY
USING OR PIMPING THE PAIN OF THE
BORDER TOWNS THAT NEED HELP AND
MAKING THE POLITICAL GRAND
GESTURES IS DISGUSTING.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK, BARBARA?
THIS IS NOT A SOLUTION TO PUT
PEOPLE ON A PLANE OR A BUS.
WHY NOT OFFER SOLUTIONS LIKE VAN
IS SAYING?
>> IRONICALLY CHARLIE BAKER OF
MASSACHUSETTS MADE THE VERY
POINT THAT VAN WAS JUST MAKING
SAYING WE NEED WORKERS IN
MASSACHUSETTS AND THANKED THE
FELLOW REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
DESANTIS FOR SENDING THE FREE
HELP TO MASSACHUSETTS BECAUSE
THEY NEED SERVICE WORKERS AS SO
MANY STATES DO AND NEED TO HAVE
A SOLUTION TO IMMIGRATION.
WE NEED TO HAVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
IN 2018 WHEN MANY REPUBLICANS, A
REPUBLICAN FROM FLORIDA, WILL
HEARD FROM TEXAS, WHEN THEY CAME
TOGETHER AND I SUPPORTED THEM TO
HAVE IMMIGRATION REFORM IT WAS A
BILL THAT DONALD TRUMP EVEN SAID
HE WOULD SIGN AND RON DESANTIS
OPPOSED IT.
I THINK A GREAT THING FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN WOULD BE TO
CONVENE PEOPLE LIKE CHARLIE
BAKER AND WILL HEARD AND CALL
THE BLUFF OF GOVERNORS LIKE
DESANTIS SAYING LET'S SIT DOWN
WITH CHARLIE BAKER.
LET'S BRING THEM TOGETHER ON THE
BORDER AND WORK ON THE SOLUTIONS
THAT THE PEOPLE WANTED TO WORK
ON, GET THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WHO WANTS A SOLUTION ON
IMMIGRATION.
WE NEED NURSES, MORE LEGAL
IMMIGRATION IN THIS COUNTRY.
I THINK YOU WOULD FIND
REPUBLICANS WHO WANT TO HELP IN
THAT REGARD.
>> PEOPLE IN BOTH PARTIES TO
TREAT THE MY GRANTS HUMANEELY.
>> THEY'RE ASYLUM SEEKERS.
WE SHOULD BE AND WOULD FIND
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS AND MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS TO SUPPORT THAT.
>> VAN, FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
HELD A RALLY LAST NIGHT FOR JD
VANCE AND THAT IS WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE THESE DAYS.
>> "THE NEW YORK TIMES" DID A
FAKE STORY TODAY.
BIG FRONT PAGE.
JD WASN'T SURE IF HE WANTED THE
SUPPORT.
JD IS KICK KISSING MY ASS.
SAID BAD THINGS BEFORE HE KNEW
ME AND THEN HE FELL IN LOVE.
>> CONVENTIONAL WISDOM SAY THEY
HELP DEMOCRATS IN NOVEMBER.
ARE YOU WORRIED THAT THE
PARTY -- THAT YOUR PARTY NEEDS
TO GET AS ENTHUSIASTIC AS THE
TRUMP RALLIES HAVE GOTTEN?
SOME WERE STRANGE LAST NIGHT BUT
THEY SEE A PATH THROUGH
MOTIVATING THE BASE.
>> THE BETTER THAT IS FOR
DEMOCRATS.
AN AMAZING THING FOR USUALLY
WHEN YOU HAVE THE CRIME AND
ECONOMIC PROBLEMS THAT YOU HAVE
YOU WANT IT TO BE A REFERENDUM
ON BIDEN.
THE REASON THAT TRUMP IS SHOWING
UP IS BECAUSE JD VANCE IS NOT
DOING WELL AND BASICALLY DONALD
TRUMP THINKS HE IS THROWING A
LIFE RAMP BUT IT IS AN ANVIL.
HE IS KISSING MY YOU KNOW WHAT.
MIGHT BE GREAT FOR A RALLY.
NOT GREAT FOR AN ELECTION.
THE MORE THAT TRUMP WANTS TO BE
THE CENTER THE BETTER FOR
DEMOCRATS.
>> WAS THAT HELPFUL TO VANCE AT
ALL?
>> I THOUGHT THAT WAS AN INKIND
CONTRIBUTION TO THE DEMOCRAT.
IT WAS HUMILIATING.
THAT RALLY LAST NIGHT WAS A
QANON FEST.
IT WAS PLAYING THE STRANGE QANON
MUSIC AND BOWING TO THIS -- I
THINK MARJORIE GREEN WAS TALKING
ABOUT THE ONE TRUE LEADER AND
NOT WELL ATTENDED.
I THINK THIS IS A DYING -- THE
LAST GASP OF A DYING CULT.
NOT THE -- I DO THINK THIS IS AN
EMBARRASSMENT.
IF I WERE VANCE A SHELL OF A
PERSON BOWING AND SCRAPING TO
SOMEBODY WHO HE RIGHTFULLY
ATTACKED JUST A FEW YEARS AGO IN
THE STATEMENTS ARE OUT THERE
PUBLICLY AND THE BEST THING FOR
TIM RYAN TO PUT THE PRIOR
STATEMENTS ATTACKING DONALD
TRUMP AND DONALD TRUMP SAYING HE
IS KISSING THE ORANGE ONE NOW.
THAT IS NOT A MAN THAT YOU WANT
TO HAVE IN THE U.S. SENATE
BECAUSE IT IS NOT SOMEONE TO
STAND UP FOR OHIO BUT SOMEBODY
TO BE KISSING THE GUY IN
MAR-A-LAGO AND BOWING AND
SCRAPING TO WHATEVER HE WANTS.
>> VAN, DEMOCRATS ARE LEANING
INTO THE ABORTION ISSUE.
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAS
BEEN LEADING THE CHARGE ON THIS
PUTTING UP BILL BOARDS IN SEVEN
RED STATES SAYING THINGS LIKE
TEXAS DOESN'T OWN YOUR BODY.
YOU DO.
IS THIS SMART POLITICS?
>> I THINK IT IS AND SINCERE.
HE IS A BELIEVER IN WOMEN'S
RIGHTS AND THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
I THINK IT IS CUTTING FOR
DEMOCRATS.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS SO
EXTREME ON THE ISSUE.
MOST PEOPLE ARE STILL WHERE BILL
CLINTON WAS IN THE '90s.
WANT ABORTION TO BE SAFE AND
LEGAL AND RARE.
GOING OUT THERE SAYING THAT
RAPISTS HAVE TO HAVE THE CHILD
OF THE RAPISTS AND THE NO
EXCEPTION AND HEAR THE HORRIFIC
STORIES AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE
CHARACTER AND THE JUDGMENT AND
RUNNING TO THE EXTREMES SO I
THINK THAT DEMOCRATS ARE NOW
BECOMING A SAFE HARBOR FOR
PEOPLE TO SAY AT LEAST LET THE
VERY DIFFICULT DECISIONS BE
HANDLED WITH SOME GRACE AND
NUANCE HERE SO I THINK THAT -- I
APPRECIATE WHAT GAVIN IS DOING.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
HAVE REPUBLICANS OVERREACHED ON
THIS ISSUE?
>> I THINK THE PROBLEM IS THAT
THE REPUBLICANS' MESSAGE IS VERY
MIXED EPA HIGHLIGHTED THIS WEEK
BY LINDSEY GRAHAM TALKING ABOUT
A NATIONAL BILL WHEN REPUBLICANS
HAVE SAID THAT WHEN THE DOBBS
CASE WAS DECIDED IT WOULD BE
RETURNED TO THE STATES AND
REPUBLICANS HAD BEEN FOR
OBVIOUSLY EXCEPTIONS.
THAT HAD BEEN MY EXPERIENCE WHEN
I WAS IN CONGRESS AND THE STATE
HOUSE AND COMPROMISE AND THEN
HAVE SEEN THE EXTREMES AND AS
VAN DISCUSSED.
SO BECAUSE OF THE MIXED
MESSAGING AND EXTREME CANDIDATES
AND MANY -- MANY MEN WHO DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT IS A PROBLEM AND SO I
THINK THE MIXED MESSAGES DRIVEN
AWAY INDEPENDENTS AND DEMOCRATS
WHEN REPUBLICANS IN ORDER TO WIN
BACK CONGRESS AND THE SW